I can't wait um so this is something
else I want to talk about okay I'm I'm
pivoting at that video she'll talk about
that video
which one the one oh just explain it
oh yeah I could explain this okay oh man
so I had I guess let's just let's just
do it like I this is this is a grotesque
warning yeah yeah this is a trigger
warning this is going to be grotesque
it's over a foul describing so if you
don't you got a you know sensitive
Tumtum
I say skip ahead yeah if you got it you
got a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] ass stomach if you
a loser with a weak ass stomach then
yeah don't listen to this [ __ ] yeah
welcome to the audio meme our so par for
the course on my daily
Twitter grind you know that's the thing
I wake up and get on Twitter like and I
think about does how awful that is
probably for my brain like to just wake
up and view some [ __ ] what I'm about to
describe
especially this yeah yeah so you know I
I'm just cruising my timeline per usual
hoping I get some really [ __ ] up and
you know lo and behold you lo behold God
gives man yeah I didn't we got the soft
shower but what we got lit yeah yeah so
basically taketh the shower earth
pressure at God giveth and he gave hit
man naked yeah yes so it gets men so
there's a so the frame first frame is a
naked old man with a [ __ ] hammer yeah
dudes got a copper yeah it ain't it
ain't it ain't a penis
it ain't a dick it's a [ __ ] yeah and
it's is it's uncircumcised yeah yeah
it's got an anteater on him that [ __ ]
just looking like a big ol [ __ ] like
Russell
nah like a like a [ __ ] like a yam to
say his body big as my dude's got some
force and he's packing force in and it
in this frame and does everything the
vibe about it like off the jump I'm like
is this a cameo yeah it seems like it
what it feels like a cameo like it's
[ __ ] up so it starts playing is like
some English dude and he's like shouting
some people out and he by the way he's
about 70 years old from yeah
yeah you know what I'm gonna just play
the audio or maybe 60 yeah I'm gonna
just play the audio yeah cuz everybody
you just need to hear the beginning of
what his voice is like oh my god that's
so [ __ ] scary
what oh yeah that's what grass will [ __ ]
is that
ah I hate Halloween costumes so
congratulations to Alex and getting
married in Hamburg and stay away from
those oranges so now he's waving his
dick back and forth he's waving his dick
so he apposite so hey then he says
congratulations who amber and whoever
whatever and then he whacks his dick
against his legs at times and now he's
reaching under his ball sack
yeah for something and by the way in the
midst of all this we miss we missed his
mint-green g-shock what the [ __ ] my man
has some [ __ ] he had to let us know i
got a [ __ ] in some drip yeah he's driven
and so now it's at 12 seconds reaching
under his boss his hands just there he's
working on something so you can probably
imagine what it is and at about 22
seconds here it's a big handful of [ __ ]
he pulls out a giant turd that he just
like picked out of his butthole and he's
got this awful grin this just cheeky
little smile like it's that this is like
cute he holds it out to the lens to be
like you see that he's bragging I just
[ __ ] that lazy you see that [ __ ] you
ain't never took a [ __ ] that big the
poop is bigger than his day get a look
at that huh yeah man
honestly the log more impressive look at
how he holds it out he unfold his and
like David Copperfield he's like yeah I
got a little trick for you look at that
look at that just [ __ ] like dude it's
like bigger than his dick head
[ __ ] dessert fondue just [ __ ] look
at that look at that brother you see
that right there he's presenting that
[ __ ]
but it's very brief because there's a
sir Martin to the video
because that very brief he holds it out
but then he's clearly intending on doing
something with the poop what it what it
is you're asking well let's keep
watching
oh and it goes right on his face on his
face because right on his face and they
just video ends do put a $17 Disneyland
fudge cake in his hand a $40 fudge
sample in his [ __ ] palm and was like
you see that right there bro yeah Pete
that good for that guy though yeah that
guy big ol [ __ ] who the [ __ ] was he
sending it to who requested it I want so
many unanswered things about that video
yeah yeah where who was it a prank
that's got to be like some only fans
type [ __ ] you don't say like he's I know
there's gonna be one person who's gonna
be like all right I'm really embarrassed
to admit this boat that's yeah old poop
mitt this poopy Greg Greg I like he's
like a bit of a meme like don't ask me
how I know who he is but like he's known
for his big-ass dick at for 40 bucks you
can get your own and he'll [ __ ] in his
hand and then eat it now he does this
thing where he eats it poopy Greg boobie
Greg
there was someone gagging on the way to
work I like that I like that I like that
power great big wig Greg poops in his
hand there's all my videos in his face
so mom the phone and I see the old man
with and he has his wee-wee out and then
he was pulling his head he put it in his
face
ah no one should that like that video
should not it I mean it's great it's
hilarious and whatever like I'm just
imagining like me watching that like
before we did any of this my head like
an outlet for it this time [ __ ] I would
watch then just go to work and people be
like oh man how you doing
I'm like like I'm dealing with some [ __ ]
yeah I'm going through something dealing
with some yeah
I'm really not good if I mean if I'm
being straight with you I'm not alright
this is what therapy is here [ __ ]
Millennials and Gen Z just gonna be
going to a guy and just talking about a
[ __ ] up she saw online my friend sent
me this [ __ ] video of this bills
mafia guy just destroying himself
missing the table and likely dying I
watched a video of a dude [ __ ] die
today and he's a dick man oh it's so
much poopoo oh that video makes you feel
a lot of things cuz not only did you
just watch him rub [ __ ] all over his
face and you're like that's [ __ ] up as
a dude you're also like well why didn't
I get that when I get the dick I mean
that doesn't that's not for everybody or
the poop why can't I produce logs of
that you can feel both okay that that
dude is like certified makes you
insecure in so many ways yeah my man
produced yeah he's like first Lieut yeah
Wow yeah yeah first up he's like I got a
huge [ __ ] secondly I take big [ __ ]
alright I do big things on this side of
the earth
I only do a big okay big dick big
[ __ ] shits that's how right wait and
third up let me show you something I'm
not afraid of what I create yeah alright
yeah watch this I'm [ __ ] insane dude
watch this [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] this
is like I yeah are you were more way
more of a man than I am sorry than me
that is the blinding confidence you need
to have like an orgy or something like
that oh yeah yeah you can the type of do
that goes to it like a nude beach and
just like just doesn't give a [ __ ] it
hits on your wife yeah yeah just walk
around take out [ __ ] arms Bach like
one his hips like this swagger about
this dicks flapping a little [ __ ]
wind doesn't even notice he's gonna call
he's doing a [ __ ] business call
walking on the beach naked
this is pretty good naked old man with
just so much [ __ ] moxie is this so
funny just watch that going to your
little tech job little little developer
job you think you're smart oh you wrote
some good code but build some nice
models some clever put some clever
methods on that figure out a nice little
way to extend that [ __ ] [ __ ] up man look
at your tiny dick
that's your tiny [ __ ] tiny poops feel
bad about yourself
well these [ __ ] up videos and he's
like where did you see this yeah he
pulls it up in the session yeah I got
take a look I got a sign I gotta see
this oh yeah that's only [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] up yeah no no this this sessions
free oh my god this is we won't build
this one this is crazy this is gonna to
go talk to someone now yeah this yeah
yeah why don't we both go talk to my
buddy just steamrolls
therapists are gonna have their work cut
out for them in the next you know 10
years or so yeah no I know Gen Z is [ __ ]
da food all right so you got addicted to
nicotine at 14 yeah all right okay come
and then you you've been on liveleak for
14 years got it so you feel nothing you
feel absolutely nothing gay got it
[Music]